y
[Música]
golpe de estado en burkina faso el
ejército tomó el control del país tras
disolver el gobierno y el parlamento el
depuesto presidente rock kaboré se
encuentra detenido la comunidad
internacional condenó el actuar de los
militares y pidió regresar al orden
constitucional analizamos en esta
emisión
eeuu y sus aliados de la otan reiteraron
su posición unánime sobre una respuesta
contundente contra rusia en caso de que
ataque territorio ucraniano
los socios sostuvieron una reunión
virtual luego de que la otan anunciara
que fortalecerían su pie de fuerza en
europa del este washington puso en
alerta elevada a 8500 soldados moscú
acusó a occidente de histeria
méxico registra el tercer asesinato de
una periodista en 2022 la reportera
lourdes maldonado murió tras recibir
disparos en el interior de su vehículo
en 2019 denunció ante el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador que temía
por su vida tras una batalla legal con
un ex gobernador del partido oficialista
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torre sánchez iniciamos
hablando del golpe de estado ocurrido en
burkina faso el ejército detuvo al
presidente roque kaboré y disolvió el
gobierno y el parlamento los militares
aseguraron que el golpe se produjo
debido a que el ejecutivo no ha sido
capaz de manejar la crisis de seguridad
que amenaza a la nación asimismo
anunciaron la suspensión de la
constitución el cierre de fronteras
aéreas y terrestres y la instauración de
un toque de queda durante la noche en
todo el territorio nacional para
analizar esta información conectamos con
ricardo benítez él es magíster en
relaciones internacionales director del
observatorio áfrica en el centro de
investigación de política internacional
de la universidad de buenos aires
bienvenido a france 24 luego de este
golpe de estado como queda la situación
de seguridad en el sahel se lo pregunto
también en el contexto en el que hay un
retiro de tropas francesas en la región
y en la situación se ve bastante
comprometida considerando que tanto chad
y malí que son otros dos estados
importantes en la región también han
sufrido un golpe de estado y esto de
alguna manera genera una complicación a
la comunidad internacional respecto a
quienes son los principales actores con
los cuales lidiar en el caso de malí el
retiro de francia ha sido destacado y
también se habla de la presencia de
rusia en la región y en el caso de
burkina faso la situación de seguridad
cada vez se complica más debido a la
presencia de elementos yihadistas que se
encuentran a lo largo de toda la región
así que en este sentido tenemos una
complicación importante los militares se
comprometen a que abra un calendario
para retornar al orden constitucional
basándose en otros golpes de estado en
la región se puede esperar que los
cronogramas se cumplan y la junta no se
quedó intentando el poder
es muy difícil considerar una
planificación exacta de un golpe de
estado usualmente cuando hay un golpe de
estado la tendencia es a generar una
devolución al golpe civil porque no se
pueden mantener a perpetuo sin embargo
lo que suele suceder es que la presión
de la región se ha cumplido regional la
presión internacional y la misma
cuestión doméstica hacen que los plazos
generalmente no se cumplan bueno y
porque la región de áfrica occidental es
tan propensa a este tipo de sublevación
es por parte de los militares
hay una gran cantidad de factores pero
basándonos específicamente en el área de
la dimensión de la dimensión de los
militares tenemos que hablar de una
fuerte crisis de seguridad una crisis de
seguridad que se encuentra tanto
potenciada por la presencia de elementos
yihadistas vinculados a estado islámico
o al qaeda en el magreb pero también una
crisis social y una crisis de
gobernabilidad que en el caso de burkina
faso la podemos retrasar a unos 30 años
atrás esta crisis políticas generan
justamente una crisis social y cuando
hay una deficiencia en el diálogo entre
el poder civil y el poder militar
generalmente son estos los que detentan
el uso de las armas y la toma del poder
brevemente le pregunto este tipo de
acciones en estos países puede servir de
ejemplo para otras naciones vecinas
creo que se puede hablar de lo que sea
también un 'efecto contagio'
generalmente áfrica occidental se
caracterizó en los 90 por tener varios
golpes de estado y en el último tiempo
se veía como una prospección a una mayor
democracia o por lo menos digamos su
gobierno civiles sin embargo tuvimos el
caso de mal y posteriormente guinea
luego chad y en la medida que suceden
los golpes de estados y aumenta la
inestabilidad y hay otros factores
locales que pueden de alguna manera
potenciarse a tomar ese tipo de acciones
por lo tanto quizás burkina faso sea el
último de estos casos o quizás uno más
en la seguidilla de la inestabilidad
regional señor benítez a usted muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo en france24 cambiamos de
tema eeuu y sus aliados de la otan
reiteraron su posición unánime de
responder duramente contra rusia en caso
de que ataque territorio ucraniano las
declaraciones se conocieron tras una
reunión virtual en la que participaron
el presidente de eeuu joe biden el
canciller alemán olaf scholz y el primer
ministro británico gordon son entre
otros previamente el pentágono informó
que 8500 de sus soldados fueron puestos
en alerta elevada y el secretario
general de la otan jens stoltenberg
aseguró que la alianza transatlántica
fortalecerá su pie de fuerza en europa
del este
estamos considerando mejorar aún más
nuestra presencia en la parte oriental
de la alianza esto podría incluir el
despliegue de grupos de batalla
adicionales de la otan
estos despliegues son proporcionados y
en línea con nuestros compromisos
internacionales y refuerzan la seguridad
europea para todos nosotros y creo que
por cobos
y
al mismo tiempo la otan permanece lista
para continuar el diálogo con rusia
permítanme ser claro la otan no se
comprometerá con los principios básicos
y defendemos los derechos de cada nación
para elegir sus propias alianzas y la
puerta de la otan y permanece abiertas y
con él tres veces primer ministro
libanés saad hariri anunció que deja la
vida política cuando faltan apenas
cuatro meses para las elecciones
legislativas en líbano el líder sunita
pidió a su partido que no participa en
las parlamentarias previstas para mayo
próximo señalando la influencia iraní
como origen de su decisión desde beirut
it'll bonet corresponsal de france 24
nos explica el impacto del retiro de
hariri
el líbano ha perdido una de sus figuras
políticas más importantes la retirada es
a dejar ir y de la vida política ha
significado que la comunidad sunita ha
quedado huérfana de líder ya que primero
su padre rafic hariri asesinado el 14 de
febrero de 2004 y después el como
heredero del partido político el
movimiento futuro y tres veces primer
ministro han representado a esta
comunidad musulmana por más de 40 años
además hariri ha sido un peso pesado en
la balanza del poder inclinándose hacia
la influencia de arabia saudita en
contraposición con su archirrival
hezbollah que representa al poder iraní
es por eso que en su discurso de
despedida ha pedido al líbano de cara a
las próximas elecciones de mayo que deje
de estar bajo la influencia iraní a
quien ha responsabilizado de haber
llevado al país al colapso total cabe
recordar que hariri dimitió el pasado
mes de julio después de no haber
conseguido formar gobierno por el boicot
de hezbollah hezbollah también ha estado
manteniendo en vilo
o gobierno libanés durante los últimos
tres meses amenazando con retirarse del
ejecutivo pero hoy por fin después desde
el mes de octubre se ha vuelto a reunir
el gabinete libanés para aprobar el
presupuesto de 2022 requisito
imprescindible para poder rescatar a
líbano el fondo monetariointernacional
la libre libanesa ha perdido más del 80%
de su valor lo que ha llevado a todos
los sectores públicos y privados a la
ruina y ha dejado a más del 70% de la
población bajo el umbral de la pobreza y
vamos a méxico donde la periodista
lourdes maldonado fue asesinada a tiros
este domingo en la ciudad de tijuana se
trata del tercer reportero en lo que va
de 2022 y el segundo en tan solo una
semana en tijuana en 2019 durante una
conferencia de prensa del presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
maldonado denunció que había recibido
amenazas de muerte tras un problema
legal que sostenía con jaime bonilla ex
gobernador del estado de baja california
y que pertenece al partido oficialista
naciones unidas- y la sociedad
de prensa exigieron justicia el
mandatario garantizó que los hechos
serán investigados
entonces se tiene
investigación
todos están
esta investigación
como todas
una característica del gobierno que
represento
por lo mismo es que no haya impunidad
todos estos
ser
entendido se investigue y se
encuentren los responsables
y
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
noticias les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
en france 24
[Música]